Rob Kardashian goes m.i.a after another  blowout fight with fiance blac Chyna  it's been like two days and I've been  texting but he blocked me on Sunday  night's episode of Robin China it seemed  all was finally well with the expecting  couple you want to move back in together  yeah but it didn't last long the two  started fighting over french fries you  are literally a psycho no you are  literally annoying tension had already  been building between the couple over  business ventures Rob wanted to take on  before their baby girl arrives I'm  trying to show her that I could do this  and it's still not good enough for her  it's pretty clear that China doesn't  support me but since the episode was  filmed the couple seems to be back on  good terms the pair spent some quality  time together on saturday with china's  sun king at a pumpkin patch beating  llamas and getting into the fall spirit  you love that make sure that the energy  you